[Music]
the constant challenging of something
if we're all using the same rules should
be
actually desired non-violent resistance
movements were three times as effective
as uh violent ones i am very concerned
that things will become violent
every movement needs to have
an agenda with an abc plan so the choice
is either to sit down and do nothing or
to hope that peaceful agitation wins the
day which it never has
[Music]
i mean the struggle of people for their
freedom
has always involved violence
are there occasions when the use of
violence can and should be justified
in seeking political ends i think so
and i think history teaches us that i
mean there are of course different forms
of violence
i'm not and never have been a supporter
of
terrorism uh defined as it should be
defined either individual
or that used by states but i am
a strong supporter of historically
speaking
of all the revolutions that have taken
place the slave rebellions that have
taken place in history
starting if you like with the american
revolution against british colonialism
carrying on to the french revolution the
revolution of the enlightenment
the link between the intellectuals
prior to the revolution and the
revolutionaries was very strong
the english revolution which laid the
foundations of democracy
which is why cromwell's statue is still
outside the house of commons so
far no one has argued that it should be
removed
though they don't allow stamps with
cromwell's head on it because it
requires the monarch's head on it
too and
of course in the 20th century we've had
a whole wave of
revolutions in revolutionary struggles
which have
deployed violence the russian revolution
the chinese vietnamese cuban the
huge anti-colonial struggles waged by
the vietnamese
so i'm afraid it's very difficult
studying modern and all medieval history
or early modern history to get away from
this
idea of violence and i think we have to
detach
the violence used by masses in motion
uh from acts of individual terror
carried out for whatever reason or
suicide terrorism or whatever i mean the
struggle of people for their freedom
has always involved violence because the
people they're trying to
gain independence from deploy it as well
so the choice is either to sit down and
do nothing
or to hope that peaceful agitation wins
the day
which it never has with very few
exceptions
and to throw the path open to those who
occupy
oppress and kill people
at nausea i mean this goes on today even
as we're sitting here
six wars are being waged in the united
uh in the world by the united states the
most
brutal of which which is hardly
mentioned
is the war in the yemen being waged by
saudi arabia and its allies backed by
the united states and britain
too often protest movements say what
they're against
but not what they're for i don't think
it's a choice of
either or i think both political parties
and social activism have a role and
indeed if you look throughout history
you will find that nearly all the great
social reform movements began
outside of parliament outside of formal
political parties
they began as grassroots movements and
eventually got translated
and adopted by political parties so if
you want to bring about change
the mechanism in our society is through
a parliamentary legislative process
ultimately all social movements need to
elect
members of parliament who will make
those changes happen
i would say that one of the big problems
with a lot of
activism has been it's often negative
oppositionist nature too often
protest movements say what they're
against
but not what they're for and that to me
undermines their credibility and success
because to persuade the public
you not only have to critique what is
you have to have an agenda for what
could be
and i think that's one of the great
failings sadly of the occupy movement
which i was very supportive of
it didn't really have a plan about
how the ideas that it espoused
could be translated in practical
legislative reforms
at the end of the day every movement
needs to have an agenda with an abc plan
i'll just give you one example as you
will recall
up until the mid-1990s the lgbti
community was
a victim of grave harassment by the
police throughout the country
with thousands of gay men being arrested
every year
for consenting adult same-sex behavior
which was not a crime between
heterosexual men and women
we went to initially do negotiations
with the police
new scotland yard and other police
services around the country
they were polite they smiled they shook
our hands
they gave us tea and sandwiches but then
went away
and continued their pattern of arrests
and harassment
so the group that i was involved in
outrage decided to leave we thought this
was just a
police pr exercise they were inviting us
to pretend and project that they were
actually engaging
with the lgbti community when in reality
nothing had changed
so we began a very high profile campaign
of direct action
against the police we occupied police
stations
we interrupted the press conferences
other than metropolitan police
commissioner
paul condon we exposed undercover police
entrapment operate operations
secretly photographing undercover police
officers
who were going into parks and public
toilets waving their willies
and then arresting any man who responded
at the end of the day that direct action
campaign
is what forced the police to rethink
they were so embarrassed because we got
acres and acres of newsprint and uh
hours and hours of tv and radio coverage
our argument was
the police were pursuing a campaign of
persecution
against people who engaged in victimless
behavior
this was a irresponsible waste of police
resources
at a time when officers were claiming
they didn't have enough
staff or resources to tackle domestic
violence
rape racist attacks queer-bashing
violence
so we won the pr battle through our
direct action campaign
which got in the headlines the police
invited us back to new scotland yard
thinking they could then buy us off
again but we came back
with a concrete program of 12 policies
for a non-homophobic policing policy
practical ideas partly drawn from the
progressive policies of
police services in copenhagen and
amsterdam but partly ones we'd invented
ourselves
it completely threw the police they just
saw us as a protest group
but when we came back with practical
ideas
they were put on the spot at the end of
the day
they couldn't argue against the policies
we proposed
the fly in the ointment they threw us
was one of our proposals was to argue
for a
lesbian and gay liaison officer so they
appointed a right-wing
evangelical christian inspector john
brown
as the liaison officer we
decided rather than rubbishing we
decided to try and persuade him
so we took him to meet victims of police
harassment who told their personal
stories
and over a period of about three months
he became convinced
the police were acting inappropriately
and not
fulfilling their duty he actually became
our greatest champion
in the metropolitan police service so
there's an example of how
protest backed up with practical
credible
plausible ideas can actually bring about
change
so challenge is actually an important in
fact the most
important part of the process now the
difference
perhaps for me between engineering and
you know if we're talking about
political
um realms is that in engineering no
matter what
position you're in in this hierarchy you
all work on the same rules
you're all using the laws of physics and
nobody no matter how high they are
in a particular company no matter where
they are in society they can't use
different rules
they are not going to be able to operate
on different rules of physics
so therefore the the playing field
is one that is transparent is one that i
understand no matter where i come in in
the hierarchy
and i can understand that the status
that somebody has earned as a very good
engineer is one that is credible and
legitimate
so i trust in that
if this person is in an in an elite
position if they're at the top of the
hierarchy
they've earned it in the kind of the
social contract that we have in the
engineering world
what i would argue is that when we talk
about illi in this room in the political
realm
the difference is that we don't all play
on the same rules
and so the question that i was asked in
this topic is
should we challenge those who are elites
and should we possibly eradicate them
as an engineer i believe we should
always be challenging
those who are in any position that is
how you stress test
whether something is actually any good
the constant challenging of something
if we're all using the same rules should
be actually
desired because in the engineering world
to get to the best solution you iterate
in the science world you perform tests
over and over and over again in order to
get
to the best result so challenge is
actually an important in fact
the most important part of the process
so why should that same process not
apply to society
if we think about elite then not only
thinking about status but also about
power and i think the conversation about
power is really
important power tends to be something
that people want to
accrue and accumulate more of no people
rarely
sort of sit back and say well i have
enough power now
i'm done i'm gonna go to sleep no for
some reason something inherently about
power asks us
to continue wanting more but i don't
think it necessarily
is going to not exist i think for me
power is like fire
is like energy it is something that is
neither created nor destroyed
only the form changes you can never
create or destroy energy it only is
transformed into different
you go from light to heat to so on
and so the question for me is how are we
distributing that power
who gets to choose how how that power is
being distributed
and perhaps it's not about whether
um an elite should exist or not but how
we make sure that we're all playing by
the same rules
because right now we're not and i think
part of the reason there is this
distrust
is because i know that the rules that
the elite in the political world are
playing but are completely different
rules to me
they've set them they've set it up for
themselves they're not interested in
in changing them and there is very
little that i can do as someone who
plays on a different ball game
completely
they're playing chess and i'm here
playing handball
right completely different set of rules
and yet we're supposed to exist
in the same space and use the same
resources and so on so for me it is a
question of first principles
in that how do we make sure that the
rules that we're all playing on are the
same and then
how do we make sure that the power's
power is distributed so that you might
in the engineering world power is
distributed
but i know that i'm going to listen to
that person because they have a better
understanding of the rules than i
and i'm actually okay with that we
really need systems change or yes
i am very concerned that things will
become violent are peace and stability
just necessary casualties when there's
so much at stake
i'd want to start with a critique of the
question itself
because it's premised upon an assumption
that britain has been a historically
stable society and of course
this country had a revolutionary civil
war in the mid 17th century 150 years
before the french revolution
more recently we have the rise of
chartism the movements for democratic
suffrage during the 19th century
suffragettes and of course we had a
civil war effectively
uh with the republic of ireland and
sessions the free state
only a century ago and then more
recently of course you've got the minor
strike you've got all grief you've got
what happened with murdoch
and the press unions in the 1980s
immense social strife but where mary is
absolutely right is that
more or less that was managed through
political institutions a lot of people
were hurt
a lot of people saw their lives then
their their way of life decimated
but it didn't descend into the things we
would normally think of as
insurrectional civil war it probably got
closer than many of us think
but it didn't similarly you have
austerity since 2010
british medical journal says that there
are 120 to 130
000 excess debts which correlate with
austerity now we can have an argument as
to whether or not it caused it
we've got life expectancy falling the
average
male from a working class background in
sheffield or in glasgow of 65 years
that's when the tourists now want to
increase the pension to 70.
so even within the present moment
there's a great deal of
violence um if you're on low pay
if you're sick life isn't necessarily
that good if you're in in poverty as a
pensioner
speaking of excess debts about 30 000
people die every year they're called
excess deaths by the civil service
this is people that die of the cold
because of fuel poverty and they tend to
be older
but of course because we're not
interested in disrupting the status quo
nobody calls that what it is
which is effectively a form of social
murder 30 000 people
it's a lot we're not talking about 10 or
20 people and yet we do nothing about it
why
because it would disrupt the economic
orthodoxy
and then i'll finish with this the book
i've written fully automated luxury
communism it's a bit more pragmatic and
practical than it sounds and its
suggestions
it starts actually with a set of
analyses which probably on this
panel we agree on i think in the 21st
century we are facing several crises
which i think are existential to market
capitalism
demographic aging very difficult to care
for an aging population with a
market-based system
climate change that has problems with
regard to geopolitics resource scarcity
has problems with regards to mass
migrations
you have automation and what that could
do for under unemployment
and then finally you have what i would
call basically the continuation of the
crisis we've seen
since 2018 crisis today in the u.s
40 million people still use food stamps
it's 26 million in 2007.
people here are using food banks home
ownership in the us is now its lowest
level since the mid-1960s
homeownership here is its lowest level
since the mid-1980s
that's only going to get worse so i
think together
that panoply of crises mean that we are
going to face significant challenges to
our democratic system
so either as a society we accept the
reality of those problems
we say you know what we really need
systems change or yes
i am very concerned that things will
become violent wars and revolutions kill
people by the
millions and tens of millions stephen
we've heard that case that
peaceful engagement on its own
simply hasn't been a useful way of
changing society with the exception of a
very few cases
you have spoken out for better angels
very very publicly
would you agree with the case that tariq
has made uh no i wouldn't agree i guess
i start from the premise
that killing people is bad and killing
uh
more people is worse than killing fewer
people
so even though i i also don't support
terrorism
terrorists have killed a tiny number of
people the worst terrorist attack in
history 911 killed 3 000
typical terrorist attack kills uh a
handful
uh whereas wars and revolutions kill
people by the
millions and tens of millions and often
uh
it is true tariq listed a number of
violent events
in human history uh we did not make the
argument that these are
uh are good or justifiable these were
history's disasters
now i do believe that there are
arguments that there can be occasions in
which violence is
justified if it is the only way to
prevent greater violence
again i'm assuming that that murdering
people is bad if you disagree with that
then you can disagree with the whole
argument
and that murdering 2 million people 4
million people
20 million people is really really bad
now
did the events that we just heard result
in uh the reduction of violence
prevention of killing of even greater
numbers which
i suppose could be used as a utilitarian
argument justifying violence
the answer is in virtually all the cases
no the
french revolution was a disaster killed
two million people
led to the rise of napoleon perhaps the
world's first
totalitarian fascist dictator who began
wars of conquest that killed another
an additional four million people led to
the restoration of slavery
to the restoration of the uh monarchy
and a delay of democracy in france by
perhaps a century russian revolution
killed
several million led to the russian civil
war which killed another 9 million led
to the rise of stalin who killed
20 million there's an old cliche you
can't make an
omelet without breaking a few eggs well
it ignores the fact that people aren't
eggs
and that generally does not result in an
omelet again the chinese revolution
perhaps the most disastrous event in
history led to
the great leap forward and the cultural
revolution which killed
perhaps uh 30 to 40 million people
uh altogether time and again a violent
revolution violent
war in addition to the moral harm of
mass murder and again i mean
murder we're talking about millions or
tens of millions of people
does not result in a stable
peaceful state that saves the lives of
even more
quite the contrary now a recent study by
um maria stefan and erica chenoweth
actually
looked over the last century at violent
and non-violent resistant movement
resistance movements to put the gandhian
hypothesis to a test
that it that there are ways of
overcoming tyranny
uh using the all of the tactics that
that gandhi worked out now you could
of course be cynical about the gandhian
hypothesis by saying well he
uh tugged at the heartstrings of of the
british at an opportune moment and he
just got
lucky so they decided to count uh of the
all of the resistance movements of the
20th century
they divided them into violent ones and
non-violent ones
putting aside the question of which was
more moral that is which
murdered fewer people just ask the
question of which is more effective
now it's not the case that violent
resistance movements
always succeed or that non-violent ones
fail or vice versa
if you count them up they found that
non-violent resistance movements were
three times as effective
as uh violent ones doesn't mean the
violence are never effective but even in
terms of
sheer efficacy the non-violent ones uh
tend to have a higher success when you
say three times as effective stephen do
you mean they killed one third as few
people
no they uh three times more often they
resulted in
regime change okay that's an interesting
definition and one that i think we will
have to come back to in the in the
discussion final observation is that in
a survey of what leads to stable
democracies
uh inspired in part by the uh 2003
invasion of iraq which i think we all
agree was not a successful
uh measure to to install a
peaceful liberal democracy it in that
actually fits into a pattern
that uh decapitations of a uh
existing tyrannical regime generally
don't result
in a stable democracy i'll add with one
final observation i'm canadian
so uh we actually did achieve
independence from uh britain
non-violently and uh uh we
had took a little bit longer than the
united states uh but
the american revolution was a pretty
bloody uh and
and brutal mess as well and uh canada
has a result
it is today one of the uh most stable
least violent and most democratic
societies on earth
you can't denetwork a society you can't
unliberate a generation it's going to
take a little bit of time to win because
we're not just up against the state nor
even is the state the biggest enemy of
xr
or of the other groups like me too or
black lives matter even black lives
matter the problem is
what what the german philosopher hannah
aaron called
the temporary alliance of the elite and
the mob we're up against a temporary
alliance
of authoritarian elites who who keep
their money offshore
who are heavily invested in fossil fuels
surveillance technologies
yeah these are what these guys and of
course by by investing in
offshore that is anti-taxation they're
effectively investing in
anti-society now that's on one hand
there are large numbers of people who
need to believe that climate change is
not real
who need to believe that uh women are
subordinate to men
because in their their world will
disintegrate in the next 20 years
because of the changes we need to make
your generation cannot go back into the
box that my grandmother's generation of
women
could have to live in or gay men or
transgender people
or black people
xr for me is the latest iteration of the
new kind of protist that is there almost
a son and daughter of
2011 and the occupy movement the occupy
movement
imagined a new society and we assembled
the forms of that society on the
internet the networks and then we took
it into physical space in the form of
tent camps
and square occupation they didn't last
they were easily repressed
extinction rebellion me too and black
lives matter
take it to a visceral level to a
granular level if you think about
what blm is saying is that the wages of
whiteness
is that if a policeman arrives on a
trouble scene black people get shot and
white people generally don't
that's why these races spend all their
time on the phone trying to call the
cops
on black people for selling water on the
street what they hope
is the cop will arrive and shoot
somebody and it ain't going to be there
no that's a very different thing than
saying i need civil rights
i need civil rights for martin luther
king for malcolm x etc
stokely carmichael was really angela
davis was re was a real thing
but to say you no longer have the right
to shoot me when the cops turn up
is a different more granular thing it
demands changes of human behavior
me too demands a change in human
behavior i work in the theater sometime
the theater is undergoing a revolution
because of
the demand of female actors and
producers
no longer for their physical invasion of
their body space
under the excuse of the theater i'm not
just talking about
directors saying you know let's let's
have a drink after work you know by the
way you're getting a lovely part in my
next film
no it's about the actual physicality of
theater is changing there's no
movement that helps people act
through whether they have to do a sex
scene or a sexual violence scene
both these things exist in reality and
should be portrayed on stage
but now we have movements where we
mediate those and we allow people to
explore what is happening to them
in a much more reflective way reflective
way
than before so what i'm describing
though is the way me too
is not just transforming kind of the
agenda of feminism it's transforming
a real industry it's also transforming
um
parts of corporate life not enough there
are now tests
and courses they call them the weinstein
test in corporate life
you can you pass the test otherwise you
don't become a director of this bank
uh so the amazing thing is
that going back to exile that we've got
here
what's xr's number one demand tell the
truth
we're at a philosophy festival where
routinely people question the
possibility of truth
but i don't and i think that's another
thing there are truths
they're provisional they're
scientifically verified we need to fight
for them
of course the states are going to
repress it it's going to be wake up time
when
some quite you know i'd say you know
young and therefore inexperienced
protesters
my generation of climate protesters the
people i collaborated with and reported
on have been trying to say luke the cops
will come
soon there will be people arriving in
your camps who look unstable
you need to deal with them in a good way
you need to educate and
care for people but what the cops then
do is that they
like the evil doctor they look they look
at the thing and they go
that's an entity this occasionally it
doesn't have to be our place
another country's police it can be a
private security company you've never
heard of
they say what are they what are the
illnesses and weaknesses of this thing
how can we make them worse that's what
happens so what happened
to the tent camp outside london stock
exchange that it was quite clear
somebody was exacerbating all the
problems
and i don't believe it's the british
state i believe you know that the whole
world is now
a kind of outsourced there's a kind of
state mischief making that's outsourced
to private companies we've never heard
of you you saw it around
cambridge analytica this parent company
but we can we can defeat them we are
millions of people and what is more
they have sons and daughters who don't
want to live in a burning planet so in
the end
we can have an argument we even with the
kind of shittiest uh
private uh intelligence company do you
really want to live on a burning planet
with chaos with millions of refugees
unstoppably moving
from the global south to the north if
you want to live in that planet
go on disrupting the climate change
movement if you don't
then even it might you know you don't
like people with green hair and nose
rings fine
just do it yourself lobby your tory mp
or
your republican congressperson tell them
to stop funding climate chaos you know
violence isn't just physical violence
there's structures of violence there's
systems of violence
i think it's important to understand or
do
you know when we talk about violence
because you know obviously
violence and the different you know
violence isn't just
physical violence there's structures of
violence there's systems of violence
so you know when we if just because
there's the absence of
physical violence in a in a country
like even here for example it doesn't
mean there aren't structures of violence
um in the u.s you know having
having abortion banned in a state that
is a system and structure of violence
and you know in that case it's obviously
a direct physical effect on people
but you know austerity is the structure
of violence
um and so on and so forth so you know i
think
you know when we talk about violence
especially in the kurdish case
you know it's never been violence in an
offensive way it's been self-defense
you know the kurdish movement and
therefore the guerrilla
uh guerrillas of the gerald army
or units have never gone on on offensive
uh attacks or wars to invade somewhere
else it's always about it been about
defending defending its people and
defending its
lands so in that sense yes it's it's
it's been a necessary and unfortunately
necessary
aspect of the self-defense has been the
use
of violence in some ways but it's it's
been necessary because
you know whether it's the whether we see
from the examples whether it's the
mothers of peace
or uh people demonstrating on
on streets um and therefore the violent
repression
of the you know in that case the turkish
state against it
you know dragging mothers across the
floor who are peacefully demonstrating
who um you know when there's
demonstrations
uh tear-gassing people when people
democratically
uh run for whether it's me as mayors or
mps
imprisoning them as you know so-called
terrorists
even though they were democratically
elected you know in many ways
that kind of leaves you that kind of
takes away the option of
non-violence from you even though it's
still tried and it's
there is still that going on and the aim
is always for peace and it always should
be for peace because
when there isn't pieces people in you
know in places like the middle east
people like the kurds and
and um other oppressed peoples of the
world wherever there may be ones who are
affected the most
so the aim is for peace but
unfortunately sometimes in achieving
that
certain methods don't work
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
[Music]
you